[Música]
y este tema como
y sí
[Música]
y esta web
respecto
algo sencillo para que ustedes
y es así
en psicología
y dentro también de las escuelas
lejos de las versiones que hablan
precisa
ya sabe la familia
pregunta
a la viga
y gris
[Música]
no sé exactamente qué es
y no descarta que me brinda
aquí no había tensión
vamos a ver business
nos quisiéramos
[Música]
también
no a ellos
uu
y los padres de familia buscan un coma
dentro de las 50 del día
las redes sociales los padres de familia
están
manteniendo
[Música]
en algunas ocasiones llegaba a su nombre
sólo necesitamos
y se sabe todo
qué tanta información era precisamente
de los padres de familia
si hay niños hiperactivos en estos dos
regulares
y hay niños que han sido diagnosticados
y negativos y no son
y hay niños que están jugando
[Música]
el niño deje de jugar
de niño tiene que moverse a ciertas
edades
porque dentro de todo el juego el niño
requiere precisamente
desarrollo cognitivo físico emocional
y esto ya tiene niño con el rey como
y entonces nos preguntamos será que
estamos confundiendo al niño hiperactivo
con el niño y el juega
definir el trastorno de déficit de
atención
y es precisamente eso
es un trastorno
[Música]
a esa tensión
una mención porque la posibilidad y en
este momento hablaremos un poco más
sobre la idea
bien
por qué
es un bestial
dobles y sevilla
beneficiar quiere
que esta función precisamente en estos
aspectos
el desarrollo del niño con estas
condiciones
los aspectos genéticos y tenemos algunos
aspectos importantes
[Música]
quien efectos importantes desarrolla
dentro de lo que es el corazón también y
después del parto
tiempo
y especialmente en la falta de oxígeno
hipoxia
puede desarrollar en el niño conductas
interactivas
en niveles ambientales estamos
precisamente trabajando
si el niño desarrolla estas
características
dentro de la casa
a la escuela y entonces no se
generalizan las conductas
y nos digas
tenemos
personas y guantes
15 los psiquiatras
sicólogos
bajitos y diarios y algunos aspectos
dentro de lo que es la neurología pero
yo sé funciona más en el aspecto del
desarrollo residente
es un tema de controversia de
comunicación
pero bueno esta es la parte
otro este como lo hemos hablado
pero entonces
[Música]
y hacemos con los niños
en ciertas ocasiones dentro de las
escuelas nos llama la atención
los que juegan en atención
y entonces deja de funcionar
dentro de los niños del desarrollo
normal muy diferente de los niños
12 de la casa década
estaba
accionando en ese cuerpecito del niño y
el libre flotaba toda la energía
wanted el día de los niños
y ahorita se detectaran en realidad y
entonces estamos hablando que a partir
de los 7 años
y en la posibilidad de darnos
y ese día
como puede ser verdad
y
y hemos preguntado
el niño perdida porque el niño si no se
lleva
porque no todos tienen la posibilidad d
con leche
un chocolate
incluso los padres de familia animal
como noche lo que se aprende
[Música]
y entonces
trujillo
requiere de una
pero no todos los niños que
especializamos en el ine
cuando esté cero
ya no es mi mano estoy enamorado
por qué
[Música]
quebrar
y entonces el niño
desborda la energía dentro del salón de
clase
y probablemente
i
es bastante de frecuencia de todas las
conducta
antes
podría ser porque berardi
de esa semana
o de esa semana
en él
[Música]
de niño d
entonces los padres
cómo
acciones dentro del hotel entero
del facebook como dice
y estamos así como determinando cómo
quitar hay casi la lista de ejecución
precisamente para poder depositar
as
así como se vengan a miles de
valoraciones
internet
en este caso una
la distracción habla precisamente de los
síntomas en el arte
y de lo que tiene que jugar
no
estamos frenando precisamente las
actividades y las acciones
no mi amor como decir
difíciles como para llevar adelante
de nuevo demasiado botín escolar
[Música]
todos los juegos que puedas
desde hace tiempo volar
frenamos el desarrollo del niño
totalmente
y ahí yo dije que un gas
por el juego desarrolla todas las capas
incluso la ley en el desarrollo
cognitivo la imaginación la creatividad
[Música]
y los estamos frenando
entonces yo le haré con ustedes que
vuelva es importante en el niño
dice
un niño y un adulto que no sabe pensar
es el tiempo de caridad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]